he has a new book out called walking
miracle how faith positive thinking and
passion for football brought me back
from paralysis
and helped me find purpose
joining us here on the rich eisen show
mercedes-benz van phone line is none
other than ryan shazier how are you ryan
how you doing rich how you doing i'm
doing fine how are you doing
i'm doing great i'm doing great where
have i found you
hey
where is where are you right now
i'm actually
on my way back to pennsylvania i was in
ohio okay i went to that i went to that
thrilling game
on the ohio state versus duke game
and
uh
unfortunately something happened so i
had to leave a little bit okay i made it
i wanted you so that's why i'm in the
car right now so how was that game last
night how about that it was
it was crazy it was crazy um you know
normally when i play games
uh or i'm really confused
i'm normally on the team that's
on the side of yeah we're gonna win the
game
but uh last night
i went into the game you know wishing
the best but you know
i kind of had in my mind that it was
there was a possibility that he was
gonna lose last night so
uh being the underdog and being on the
upsetting side of being on the upsetting
side was actually pretty
pretty cool experience you know it's
pretty exciting experience so it was
kind of
it was really crazy there and really fun
but we had a really good time yeah i had
that feeling on saturday ryan
you know
[Applause]
[Laughter]
oh my gosh yeah
you walked into it man yeah
did you though did you though because a
lot of ohio state folks don't really
feel that way you know yeah it's ohio
state alabama schools like that like
clemson is going through it right now
um we're so used to winning everything
yes when you lose it feels crazy like
it it feels like this
it doesn't make any sense well i'm sorry
i'm glad that you're calling in right
now ryan after that big win uh against
duke last night because i want to
welcome you to being a basketball school
um you know so
welcome to being a basketball school
we're not a basketball school
[Laughter]
[Music]
i'm just giving you ryan i'm giving you
what i've been getting for the last 10
years you know um i'm giving you all the
lines i got from ohio state
buckeyes like yourself although you
never said it to me i'm just describing
what i've heard from so many others with
juwan howard doing such great things
with michigan's basketball program after
john beeline last ten years all i've
heard is your basketball school so i
guess i figured after that great win
against duke
you know i forget how to give that to
you you know
rich yes brian yeah you guys beat us two
times in the last 20 years just know you
have another 10-year streak coming
well the neat thing is i've got what is
that let me do the math here i've got
352 more days in terms of waiting to
find out so it'll be great it'll be
great uh congrats on your book here ryan
um
and i'm wondering what uh what you want
people to know about this book
ryan chaser uh
one thing that i'm really excited about
this book is
that
i think it can just touch everybody you
know a lot of people like football but i
think the church of everybody because
this this last year
is everybody's been going through some
really crazy adversity with kovid and
just
you know mass nomads and just everything
that's going on and i think it's a
really
good book for just letting people know
how to overcome adversity and no matter
what situation you come in and
also it lets you know that
you know you never know
what can happen like life's changes in
the instance you know situations happen
in the instance
you just never know
you can't control what you can't control
so i think it's a good way of explaining
that to people and allowing people to
understand how to overcome those type of
situations and deal with those
situations and it's just it it's it's
for any situation clearly is what you're
referring to right it's any situation
that you find yourself and obviously you
found yourself in a very dire situation
but for anybody that needs to to
understand
what to do to overcome odds to overcome
obstacles to overcome
whatever
hits you right in your regard um that
you can overcome it
yeah yeah that's exactly that's exactly
what i mean by that because
there's so many people
in their whole life they go through
adversity they go through trials they go
through
trials and tribulations and you just
never know
what may happen to you me for instance
me being you know nfl after me i never
thought
a day of my life that the next the next
time uh next time i'll be the next day
or the next play i'll end up being
paralyzed you know sometimes people this
this whole world we never thought a
virus was gonna shut us down for two
years
you know and people you know some people
never think that they'll ever get cancer
and
and to me i feel like in different ways
that people go to adversity but
it's the same steps and the same type of
positivity the same type of
willing and faith that can help you
overcome all those things to help you
push through those things and i think
this book is a good way to explain
people how to how to find a way to
to get through it walking miracle is the
name of the book and that is in
reference to what ryan
so my job
before i even started walking
she was like you're going to be a
walking miracle and
i was wearing that bracelet the whole
time i was doing my rehab
and i was wearing it so much it was more
out now i don't have it anymore but i
was just wearing the bracelet and as i
was going through all my rehab
and my whole family said hey ryan's
gonna be a walking miracle and i'm you
know i'm gonna get through this nobody
in my family ever thought
that i would never walk again and if
they did they didn't tell me because i
didn't want any negativity i didn't want
anybody to have any doubt
on my vision or my goals and
so that's why we came up with the name
walking america for the book because
you just i had a 20 chance to walk i had
so many doubts against me and it's not
even people are doubts but it's just the
statistics you know from all the spinal
cord injuries that happened before me
and
um to be able to overcome that and be a
walking miracle i thought i was the
right the right name for the book it's a
beautiful name for the book man and uh
ryan chazy are here on the rich eisen
show how are you now what can you tell
us about your your your current
abilities right now i'm i'm doing great
right now uh i'm i would say i'm about
85 percent i can pretty do pretty much
do most things
that are a regular person to do
obviously i still have some
disability that i can't do like for
instance if i have a dog chasing me uh i
don't know how far i'll get you know
i think he'll still catch me uh but you
know but i like i ride my bike but i
have like a pedal assist bikes
so it helps me keep going and it helps
me going in the right direction
but i i'm doing great i'm feeling
amazing i get to spend a lot of time
with my family it's a lot of time with
my kids and i'm actually
helping a lot of people right now so i'm
really excited about that how old are
your kids
so i have a two-year-old and a
seven-year-old
two-year-old uh i know what are they
boys girls one of both
um i have two boys one other name is
ryan uh the second and then my
understanding name is lion
lion
yeah
okay l-i-o-n l-y-o-n
okay
that is dope right exactly and so um
what uh what do you think about the
current state of the steelers ryan let's
talk about that a little bit let's talk
a little football oh man
you're just trying to hurt my heart
today uh no i i in all honesty uh i i
love your coach i i i believe in him i
trust in him
um and you know i and and and that
running back is somebody who can you can
hang the bell on him you know
so
he spells it right um to me this is this
is what i think these feelers are kind
of going through right now
um the whole season i feel like we
really didn't have an identity
and and uh and what we wanted to do on
the opposite side of the ball we found
our identity then we kind of got away
from it
and on the defensive side of the ball
uh we obviously were going through some
hiccups god didn't hurt
but i i believe in coach thomas so much
that i feel like he's going to figure
out a way
to you know probably finish off 88
in one you know right
but i but he's he's such a great coach i
think he can figure a way out to
to make things fall in the favor of the
team
but sometimes
it doesn't seem like the team plays with
that much want to order that much you
know effort like for instance this game
versus the bengals you kind of seen it
this week the bengals wanted it more
than it still is and it's kind of the
same thing with our state game you guys
won you can see it on the field you guys
wanted to win that game
more than we wanted to win that game and
to me
something that that football's a game
about will a game about warranty but
then also
uh like for instance with chase
sometimes you got a state like you have
to focus on
like what's important right now you're
not playing well as a team
you know when somebody asks you what you
can do better you know talking about
dancing and music that's not
that's not the focus of what you need to
be in so i think
something's gonna help them redirect
their focus on what's important what
helps them be stealing football
and to me uh i looked at the stats every
time naji has over
uh
20 carries i think they have one game
that they tied
but every other game they want so i
think they need to just figure out a way
to give him over 20 carries and that
keeps us in the game but if we get
behind later it really is really
difficult well uh tomlin outside of the
football world and uh in your book you
do feature
him how did he uh
what did he mean for you to you assist
you when you went down ryan and your
journey
so to me it was it was really close i
wouldn't call him like a father figure
because i have a father um but
i would say he's like a step away from
that because the reason i say that when
i was playing
the way i used to talk to him and
discuss things with him and about the
game of football
it made me feel really comfortable but
then when i got hurt and even before i
got hurt you know i would talk to coach
tomlin about situations that were going
on in my life
and he just made me feel you know
comfortable
to be able to talk to him about those
type of things
and it really made me feel good to have
somebody like that on my side when it
came to a coach because when this
situation happened tim kevin coburn mr
rooney they were all right there beside
me pushing me forward and wanted to see
what's best for me and they didn't just
treat it like hey this guy's injured
let's keep let's move on and do what we
have to do
uh they they were like hey we're going
to support ryan be there for ryan and
trust that you know his best will for
him and his family and even now to this
day
me and coach thomas still taught him
kevin cover still taught me some really
talk and
uh that's why you know
coach thompson is on my board of my
foundation um they're very
all three of them in the whole
organization and the city of pittsburgh
has been really supportive of me and my
family since i've been going through
this injury and it's been it's been
amazing well walking miracle is the name
of the book uh by you and larry platt
who um co-authored stuart scott's
posthumous bestseller and you know what
stewart means to me and who he means to
me so it's a beautiful book it's a great
book everyone should go get it
um and you know the people that you have
giving you testimonials snoop
you got snoop giving you a testimony for
the book that's good right you know
snoop very well
yeah i i know him a little bit i know
it's right it's pretty cool experience
when you you get to play for the
skillers because
you started to
grow on people
and then i had a
friend
who is a business partner with mark
wahlberg and he i just wanted to make
sure he checked it out and i taught him
before because he had opened a
restaurant here and i supported that
so
it was it was pretty cool to have those
have those guys be like
a book and uh be able to
uh call those guys uh you know queenies
uh it's awesome i love it and also yeah
you get you got a quote from gene smith
who's the senior vp and athletics
director at the basketball school we're
referring to right ohio state
[Music]
i actually saw him last night it was
really good he must have been very happy
because you know basketball wins are
great um so that's cool
i did i gave i gave a book i gave a book
to coach k as well i didn't get to see
him but i i i sent one to him um i don't
know if
if that was you know
uh
a way of just like telling them like you
know a little house they win and i'm
messing around with okay you know but
hey hey rich uh taught me back in the
year uh in this and listen how many
jokes you have about it
[Laughter]
brian
[Applause]
ryan i intend i don't want to lose touch
with you i intend to call you every day
i have to tell you
i enjoy talking to you right back at you
ryan i'm i'm thrilled for your book
everyone should go get it walking
miracle by ryan shazier let's let's do
this more often we'll chat soon
take care
okay there you go okay there you go that
could either be ryan or lyon back there
in the in the car that was great
wow call me back in a year that's
amazing
i have his number i'm calling him
tonight
[Laughter]
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here